accalmie est reprise en main en inde peu
d'incidents aujourd'hui à new delhi le
premier ministre a complété son
gouvernement
raymond barre demain soir à l'heure de
vérité sur antenne 2 l'étape peu
médiatique d'un parcours politique en
solitaire qui s'appuie sur une trame de
réseaux tissés en province élections
générales aujourd'hui au nicaragua le
scrutin s'est déroulé dans le calme
stats de deuxième les dernières images
et les derniers résultats de la journée
sportive des vins en main un monsieur
bonsoir le calme est revenu aujourd'hui
à new delhi où la vie quotidienne a
repris ses droits
le couvre feu toujours en vigueur dans
certains quartiers de la capitale
indienne doit être progressivement levé
à partir de demain
le bilan officiel des affrontements
entre hindous et sikhs depuis mercredi
dernier et de plus de 450 morts dans la
capitale
11 100 dans tout le pays 2000 blessés et
dix mille arrestations des centaines de
milliers de sikhs ont cherché refuge
dans des camps contrôlés par le
gouvernement et la croix rouge eynden
sur place olivier varin et patricia cost
l'armée a remplacé la police dans les
grandes villes indiennes
ici dans la capitale new delhi 22 mille
soldats se seraient déployés et
patrouille l'armée rassure le calme est
revenu
la police en revanche a été accusée de
passivité le chef de la sécurité a été
limogé ce matin ils payent pour le bilan
des affrontements qui s'alourdit au fur
et à mesure de la découverte de nouveaux
cadavres comme ceux qui sont apparus ce
matin a transmis brûlé flottant à la
surface des eaux de
rivière je délire
le vilain du ciel 4 158 morts
mais la presse parle de 11 100 morts les
biens et les magasins des sikhs ont
également été pillés terroriser les six
se sont regroupés dans des camps protégé
par les forces de l'ordre et il l'aura
été distribués pour la première fois de
l'eau et de la nourriture
seule lueur en ce lendemain d'horreur
une petite manifestation unitaire
hindous et ses frères hindous et sikhs
frères scandaient les participants à
cette manifestation spontanée de
fraternité entre les deux communautés
veut que sans aucun doute ils ont tué
nos femmes et nos enfants nous dit
celui-ci brûlé nos maisons et nos
temples le temps de la vengeance viendra
l'heure et lan et il sera extrêmement
difficile pour ces deux comme mosquée de
réapprendre à vivre ensemble
pourtant le premier ministre rajiv
gandhi reprend la situation en main il a
limogé aujourd'hui le responsable de la
sécurité à new delhi il a complété son
gouvernement rpt conduisant le même
cabinet que sa mère à l'exception
notable du ministre qui détenait en jeu
dernier au moment de l'assaut contre les
sikhs au pendjab
le portefeuille de l'intérieur rajiv
gandhi qui gardent comme sa mère les
portefeuilles des affaires étrangères et
de l'énergie a aussi mis à profit la
présence à new delhi de nombreux chefs
d'état et de gouvernement pour affermir
son autorité internationale philippe
rochot en quelques heures cet homme qui
a prêté serment le jour de l'assassinât
de sa mère a hérité d'une nation de 700
millions d'indiens
rajiv gandhi ne pourrait sans doute
trouver meilleure occasion de
s'installer au pouvoir car il a été
littéralement porté par le charisme de
sa mère le nom qu'en dit il l'a déjà
mais il sait qu'il ne pourra tenir le
pays comme la fête il dira c'est elle
qui l'a imposé à la tête du congrès le
parti majoritaire qui est devenue
l'instrument d'un pouvoir personnel
divisé en clans c'est lui qui a porté sa
mère au bûcher lors des funérailles et
qui a reçu comme elle
l'ovation de la foule on les tenait pour
qu'entité politique négligeable un homme
sans autorité on dit qu'il a sous-estimé
la crise qui devait conduire à
l'assassinât de sa mère mais à présent
qu'il tient le pouvoir
il devra savoir évaluer les risques de
fracture dans le pays pratiquement 10 en
deux jours accueillis ici une trentaine
de chefs d'état comme julius nyéréré le
président tanzanien autant de pays qui
ont les yeux tournés vers l'inde et non
alignés dont l'inde reste le leader lyon
accordé leur confiance et il a tenu à
les rassurer et le cas me reviendrait
vite que c'était déjà commencé que la
situation redeviendra normale dans
quelques jours qu'il attendait enfin
poursuivre la politique de sa mère lui
rappelant le slogan qui lui était cher
alors la politique de l'inde n'est ni
pro soviétique ni pro-américaine et les
pros indienne le premier ministre indien
a reçu tout à l'heure le général zia le
président du pakistan qui est l'ennemi
héréditaire de l'inde
auparavant il s'était entretenu avec son
homologue français laurent fabius
laurent fabius qui a réaffirmé la
volonté de la france de poursuivre une
coopération privilégiée avec l'inde
demain à l'aube les cendres d'in dire à
gandhi seront prélevés sur son bûcher
funéraire des urnes en seront remplies
qui pendant une semaine sillonneront le
pays tout entier à bord de trains
spéciaux pour que la population puisse
lui rendre un dernier hommage dimanche
prochain les cendres seront dispersées
au dessus de l'himalaya avoir ce vie
c'est un véritable pèlerinage que les
polonais accomplissent déjà dans le
jardin de
guy saint stanislas où est enterré le
père popieluszko selon sa famille le
prêtre a été torturé et battu à mort par
ses ravisseurs
les résultats officiels de l'autopsié
n'ont toujours pas été publiés
en france la vie politique est bien
ralenti en ce dimanche le président du
rpr jacques chirac était toute à l'heure
l'invité du club de la presse de europe
1 précisant les propos qu'il avait tenus
récemment au journal libération
jacques chirac a déclaré qu'il ne
demandait pas qu'on revienne sur la loi
autorisant l'avortement mais inquiet de
la banalisation de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
jacques chirac souhaite une politique
qui dissuaderait les femmes d'y recourir
un sondage qui va faire du bruit dans la
classe politique le sondage que publie
l'hebdomadaire le point et qui analysent
différents scénarios en cas d'élection
présidentielle si l'élection
présidentielle avait lieu actuellement
françois mitterrand dans tous les cas de
figure serait battu au second tour
jacques chirac serait le meilleur
candidat de l'opposition au premier tour
et valéry giscard d'estaing ferait le
meilleur score au second
pourtant la personnalité de l'opposition
qui depuis plusieurs mois est en tête de
son dalles des sondages de popularité
des présidentiables
c'est bien raymond barre l'ancien
premier ministre sera demain soir à
20h35 lavit et de l'heure de vérité sur
antenne 2 une étape importante dans un
parcours en marge des formations
politiques et qui s'appuie plutôt sur
des réseaux patiemment tissé en province
l'enquète de patrick de carolis jeu
solitaire au dessus des partis
sans organisation ainsi peut-il apparaît
depuis 1981 raymond barre est sans doute
l'homme politique de l'opposition qui a
prononcé le plus de 10 courts couverts
le plus de kilomètres
objectif expliquer sa politique mais
surtout multiplié les contacts avec des
leaders d'opinion ainsi au fil de ses
voyages
et bien qu'il s'en défende il a tissé
avec discrétion et minutie une trame
d'amitié qui ressemble fort à un réseau
d affabulations il n'y a pas de réseau
jeudi sera le jeu dispose d'un certain
non
ça patine
pourtant il ya une logique dans ses
déplacements l'activité politique de
raymond barre ne se résume pas à des
réunions publiques
il prend soin à chaque voyage
d'entretenir des contacts privés avec
des politiques des socioprofessionnels
des universitaires ces différentes
rencontres comme celles ci sont riches
en confidences et les micros ne sont pas
toujours les bienvenus
cette image symbolise la stratégie de
l'ancien premier ministre
chacun de ces hommes est à la tête d'une
association socio professionnelles
culturelles de la région lyonnaise
ils représentent une force de
mobilisation importante
en mai dernier ils ont organisé à
valence un meeting pour raymond barre
résultat huit mille personnes paris
boulevard saint germain
un immeuble bourgeois seule indication
au deuxième étage une carte de visite
secrétariat de raymond barre c'est ici
que se réunissent dans la discrétion les
fidèles de l'ancien premier ministre
un noyau de vos fonctionnaires qui
préfère garder l'anonymat
ce qu'elle travaillait à visage
découvert cède à l'assemblée nationale
que nous les trouvons ici pas de mystère
charles millon françois d'aubert jacques
barrot pierre méhaignerie et bernard
stasi constituent entre autres une
véritable force de frappe barriste ce
travail de pénétration des partis c'est
l'oeuvre de philippe mestres député de
vendée est montbarla chargé d'appliquer
sa stratégie de conquête politique
si bien qu'aujourd'hui 70 % des députés
udf se dit ouvertement baltes
roger un réseau d'associations et de
notables une équipe d'experts des
troupes de choc à l'assemblée nationale
des troupes de réserve au sénat où le
groupe centriste lui quasiment favorable
tout cela montre que raymond barre n'a
rien laissé au hasard
une manière sans doute de répondre à
ceux qui le présentent ou veulent le
présenter comme un simple économie
l'opération manta est pratiquement
terminée le général déchu le chef des
forces françaises au tchad l'a déclaré
ce matin lors d'une prise d'armes
n'djamena en présence du chef d'état
major des armées le général la case
comme prévu le retrait français sera
achevé à la fin de la semaine prochaine
on a voté aujourd'hui au nicaragua pour
la première fois depuis la prise du
pouvoir par le front sandiniste en 1979
ces élections auquel ne participe à un
nombre de partis de l'opposition se sont
déroulées dans le calme sur place à
managua
bernard benyamin larmes dans une main le
bulletin de vote dans l'autre plus que
jamais le mot d'ordre était présent dans
tous les esprits aujourd'hui au
nicaragua dans tout les cas qui se sont
formées dès 7 heures du matin devant les
bureaux de vote
les militaires les premiers se sont
présentés devant les urnes et autant que
nous avons pu le constater une extrême
régularité régnait à l'intérieur des
bureaux de bulletins multicolores l'un
pour désigner les députés l'autre pour
le président et le vice-président était
à la disposition des électeurs qui après
le passage obligatoire dans l'isoloir
pouvait exercer leur droit de vote
cela dit personne ne doute une seule
seconde du résultat c'est daniel ortega
le candidat du front sandiniste qui sera
élu président de la république
en fait les deux seules inconnues sont
les suivantes d'abord le score que
réalisera le commandant ortega ensuite
le nombre d'abstentionnistes tous les
déçus du régime qui refuse de participer
à ce qu'ils estiment être une farce
électorale
raul est de ceux là il est avocat et ne
sortira pas de son jardin aujourd'hui
je suis sandiniste dit raúl est mais la
seule chose que je puisse faire pour le
front c'est de ne pas aller voter afin
que les sandinistes comprennent les
erreurs qu'ils sont en train de
commettre
bref ce sont des élections jouées
d'avancé sans passion mais qui vont
donner lieu à des réjouissances
populaires bien dans la tradition du
nicaragua tout à l'heure sur cette place
on va danser on va danser toute la nuit
entre deux résultats électoraux
on va fêter la victoire du front de la
même manière que les écoliers les
lycéens savent déjà qu'ils auront congé
jeudi prochain pour célébrer le triomphe
de daniel ortega pour les candidats
america l'élection présidentielle de
mardi prochain ce sont les derniers
discours et les derniers meetings
d'après le sondage publié ce matin par
le washington post
ronald reagan disposerait de 18 points
d'avance survolteur mondale au delà du
sort du candidat démocrate qui pourtant
n'avoue pas forfait c'est tout un parti
qui continue de payer pour carter
edouard nord 20 janvier 1981 jimmy
carter quitte la maison blanche
le dernier président que toute
l'amérique démocrate aujourd'hui essaye
d'oublier et sans lui avoir trouvé un
successeur
une petite lueur d'espoir avec le
sénateur edward kennedy
mais qui s'effacera pour des raisons
familiales c'était le prétexte officiel
devant l'ancien vice-président de jimmy
carter walter mondale le premier des
démocrates a annoncé sa candidature
une deuxième nuit hors d'espoir avec un
jeune sénateur du colorado
gary hart est le premier candidat noir à
la présidence des états unis
geci jaxxon quand je parle des leaders
démocrates roosevelt truman kennedy mes
adversaires s'arrachent les cheveux
ça montre à quel point ils sont
aujourd'hui loin de la tradition
politique des démocrates complètement
écarter les gars yart ou g6 jackson
walter mondale habile politicien se doit
dans un premier temps de ressouder le
parti démocrate qui va le tenter à
travers la nomination de son colistier
première femme candidate à une vice
présidence aux états unis première
réaction de l'électorat américain
agréablement surpris walter mondale au
nom des démocrates enchaîne sur une
campagne qui l'amène à traverser une
dizaine de villes par jour après s'être
partagé le territoire américain avec
geraldine ferraro pourtant à l'euphorie
des premiers jours va succéder très vite
un certain désenchantement dans le camp
démocrate geraldine ferraro reste au
deuxième plan walter mondale ne soulève
aucune passion s'énerve même de temps en
temps
les trois fameux débat tests que l'on
donnait comme décisif n'ont rien changé
walter mondale a été bon sans plus
ronald reagan comme on l'attendait cela
dit au delà de walter mondale il faut
poser le problème des démocrates du
parti démocrate face à ronald reagan
personne ici ne se fait et ne se faisait
aucune illusion il ya déjà bien
longtemps qu'on se prépare pour un autre
objectif 1988 ou de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive les républicains auront à
présenter un autre candidat et donc pour
ce qui est de cette élection
le grand problème des démocrate de
walter mondale n'est pas tellement de
perdre mais de perdre sans que cela
apparaisse comme une débâcle demain dans
le journal le monde et dans nos
différentes éditions vous découvrez un
sondage bien intéressant un sondage sur
la manière dont les français voient les
états unis l'image de l'amérique à la
veille de cette élection présidentielle
au proche-orient report des négociations
militaires entre israël et le liban à la
demande de beyrouth
les négociations devaient s'ouvrir
demain pour des raisons techniques et
logistiques et n'auront lieu que dans
quelques jours à jérusalem arrestation
et inculpation aujourd'hui de deux
soldats israéliens
il aurait participé à l'attentât
perpétré le 28 octobre dernier contre un
autobus arabes à jérusalem pour la
première fois dans l'histoire politique
italienne une personnalité de premier
plan arrêtée pour appartenance à la
mafia il s'agit de l'ancien maire
démocrate chrétien de palerme qui
pendant 25 ans a dominé la vie politique
chilienne
corinne pertuis la commission antimafia
a bien joué vito ciancimino ancien maire
ancien responsable des travaux publics
de la ville de palerme a été arrêté à
l'origine de son arrestation les
confessions du par un repenti tommaso
bush et à des confessions qui avait déjà
amené les juges de palerme a déclenché
le 29 septembre une vaste opération
contre la mafia
ce que l'on reproche à ce personnage clé
de toutes les combinaisons politiques à
la mairie de palerme depuis 25 ans ce
qu'on lui reproche et claire
c'est son appartenance à la mafia et
l'exportation illégale de capitaux à
l'étranger aux états unis notamment
aujourd'hui ciancimino a été transféré
de la prison de palerme à celle de rome
pour des raisons de sécurité c'est tout
en espagne hier soir neuf personnes sont
mortes et deux autres blessés dans une
explosion due sans doute à des aérosols
il y en avait huit tonnes dans les cars
de l'une des maisons qui ont explosé
thierry calmette
voici ce qui reste des deux pavillons
soufflé par l'explosion les sauveteurs
ont retrouvé neuf corps sous les
décombres
parmi eux trois enfants l'explosion
s'est produite vers 18 heures de famille
regardait la télévision c'était
l'anniversaire de l'un d'entre eux à
l'origine du sinistre huit tonnes d'or
au sol entreposés dans le sous-sol d'une
des maisons
la déflagration a secoué la petite ville
de mende et rappeler deux habitations
ont été pulvérisés ces huit tonnes
aérosols rempli de laque pour cheveux
appartenaient aux propriétaires des
pavillons les acheter par grosses
quantités à madrid et les vider de leur
contenu
les atomiseurs ainsi récupérer devait
être revendue
les enquêteurs n'ont pu encore
déterminer la cause exacte de
l'explosion des atomiseurs et on sait
que généralement ceux ci doivent être
stockés à l'écart des sources de chaleur
et ne doivent en aucun cas être percés
amont des rares le travail des
sauveteurs étaient entravés par les
explosions à retardement de plusieurs
centaines d'atomes isr encore enfouis
sous les décombres
deux morts dans le hold up sanglant
d'hyères à la samaritaine l'un des
malfaiteurs est aussi le convoyeur de
fonds qui avait été grièvement blessé et
qui est mort dans la nuit
il s'apprêtait à prendre sa retraite des
médecins en colère aujourd'hui avignon
des médecins spécialistes et les
congressistes de l'union syndicale de la
médecine auquel le ministère des
affaires sociales refuse le droit de
négocier la future convention médicale
parce qu'ils le jugent non
représentatifs madame du foie qui
assistait ce matin au congrès est resté
seul à la tribune les congressistes
ayant quitté la salle en signe de
protestation
le champion du monde d'othello à 16 ans
et il est français
othello ce n'est pas du shakespeare
c'est un jeu de stratégie dont les
japonais qui pratiquent le go sont
grands spécialistes
sylvie marion a rencontré le plus grand
stratège français à l'aller kupka
monfils pas l'a rapporté dès melbourne
de villepinte en seine-saint-denis à
melbourne en australie ça c'est un
voyage pour halliche et anne 16 ans et
pour décrocher le championnat du monde
de thello s'il vous plaît othello vous
ne connaissiez pas grave moi non plus
mais j'ai appris que c'est un jeu de
stratégie joué par des millions
d'américains et de japonais qui fait une
entrée fulgurante chez nous premier de
sa classe de première en maths paul
râler les couverts othello il ya deux
ans seulement il est rapidement devenu
champion de villepin de france et du
monde
c'est la première fois qu'un européen va
emprunter le titre est effectivement sa
surprise les japonais qui étaient
habitués et bon ben je pense que à
partir de maintenant les européens vont
être beaucoup plus fort à othello et je
pense que les japonais vont devoir
s'entraîner beaucoup plus et cela dure
pour acheminer à quoi attribuez vous
votre talent au bas je pense que tout
d'abord côté l'osce un jeu bonfoh a fait
fort pour connaître les règles de tout
ça il faut il ya aussi une question une
importante question de psychologie il
faut que les joueurs ce mythe filbien et
notamment au cours du chemin du monde et
des joueurs qu'on craque et
psychologique on les compare ainsi à
tenir jusqu'au bout quoi notamment le
joueur italien notamment qui avait pas
un moral de gagnant par exemple il
venait pas
notre idée de gagner et du coup il a
perdu c'est ainsi qu'il ya aussi le
joueur américain
ce n'est pas tellement enfin il avait
pas un véritable moral de gagnant quoi
vous avez le moral d'un gagnant bah je
m'étais surtout fils et depuis très
longtemps qu'il fallait que je batte
absolument le japonais est bon bah je
bâtis tous les autres par conséquent
j'aimerais bien prendre ma place du
champion de ville pâte pour vous
m'expliquer un peu comme on joue pour
prendre les pions il faut vous entoure
et sur les grottes et par exemple sur
blanc est entouré par les deux noirs
donc je ne retourne un bond des mains si
je fais ça voilà c'est bon c'est ça oui
mais c'est facile alors c'est facile à
apprendre mais surtout plus dur en
excuser conne mais pour paul othello
n'est qu'un passe temps
ce qu'il aime le plus c'est la
littérature maupassant pour le style la
science fiction pour le contenu paul
râle un nom à retenir champion du monde
de thello futur écrivain je retrouve
maintenant l'accueil sportive de cette
journée avec rendent à chapeau bonsoir
c'est de belgique que nous viennent
aujourd'hui ses buts marqués l'étranger
ces bus qui met toujours leur gardien en
fâcheuse posture anderlech saint-nicolas
match phare du championnat national sur
un commentaire de notre ami de la
radio-télévision belge arsène vaillant
qui fut en son temps un international de
grande classe il donne en direction de
leur côté schiffer cantaranne et
la besoin sauf de la 5eme étape est un
très très bon moment
annoncés par beaucoup comme m
en réalité il y avait de grosses au
départ simone qui a donné de la bande et
une bonne balle elle est dangereuse elle
est très dangereuse mais metz et gol et
gol avec une reprise de la tête et
cornelissen
regarder passer ce ballon là du côté de
la défense anderlechtoise sur le centre
de la croix et nous en sommes à la vente
20e minute renaud veeckman qui amortit
pour armer semaine et c'est bon pas de
chance pour les scènes et il est là
bonne mère et sa reprise mais il n'y
avait pas de sens cela
vraiment sur la
les premières tentatives de
le faible
nous avons donc 25 minutes de jeu
ces chiffons et non par mais celle ci a
marqué par at il personne ou la longue
scène en berne au maire c'est bien fait
c'est son adversaire direct et alors que
nous en sommes à la 28e minute
le relais que mène maintenant 3 buts à
leur compteur en scène en direct
beaucoup chiffo pour van den berghe
c'est bien joué
remarquable dans sa conception
au départ
olsen le centre de l'amérique sipho et
van den berghe 4 buts à 1 à cinq minutes
du repos jalila par l'onab la peau armée
scène l'ont la passe est pas bonne ou
espérés maintenant par joe johnson
johnson qui a évité la fac de bever
encore que johnson qui a évité la tacc
de si bonnes et il ne sera probablement
là des réactions valable de cette partie
qui était
largement dominés par le sporting
d'anderlecht puisque record le score
était déjà de 4 buts à 1 la deuxième
mi-temps était soporifique anderlecht
s'est contenté de contrôler les
opérations et finalement b et s'inspire
encore un but portant le score final 5 1
c'était arsène vaillons recrues tout à
fait occasionnels de stade 2 merci
arsène six jours de grenoble marathon
istanbul golf avec des plaids petite
française qui font merveille les flashs
de daniel cazals on les appelle les
écureuils car il tourne en rond sur la
piste comme des écureuils dans une cage
les six jours de grenoble connaissent un
franc succès populaire s'il est un peu
tôt pour faire un pronostic puisque
c'est seulement lundi soir vers 23h20
jeu retentira pour la dernière fois la
cloche annonçant le dernier clou
redisons que les deux équipes aient plus
afitf moser bidean host et franck va les
vainqueurs au début de l'année des
premiers six jours de bercy excellentes
performances des jeunes golfeuses
françaises qui ont terminé 2e des
championnats du monde amateurs
derrière les intouchables américaines
cecily amoureux d'algues corinne soulès
et valérie pamart ont été
particulièrement brillante sur les
greens de tokyo mais matthew la donne
est là quelque part perdu parmi les
douze mille marathonien d'istanbul qui
franchissent tu ici le pont enjambant le
détroit du bosphore entre l'europe et
l'asie mais met your d'adn a passé un
bon week end il a remporté ce marathon
d'istanbul en deux heures 22 minutes et
18 secondes
cet après midi à lisbonne le portugais
caetano a été le plus rapide dans le
marathon de lisbonne en deux heures huit
minutes et 5 secondes
tennis maintenant au tournoi de
stockholm
excellent parcours de guy forget jusqu'à
sa défaite en quarts de finale face à
mats wilander tenant du titre et
vainqueur aussi de connors en demi
finale déjà un avant-goût de la coupe
davis suède états unis d'amérique
puisque deux américains étaient opposés
à deux suédois henri leconte associé à
thomas schmidt en finale du double
demain danil cazals encore lui et oui
finale 100% entre les états unis et la
suède ici connard au premier plan est
opposé à max wilander que nice va perdre
en trois sets 6-3 pardon 6 7 6 3 6 3
pour wilander 12 ans séparent les deux
joueurs car que l'ours à 32 ans alors
que wilander a une vingtaine d'années
connors a gagné 105 tournoi et vilander
lui en a gagné quinze mais il est
évident qu'il a encore l'avenir devant
lui cette année les deux hommes se sont
déjà rencontrés une fois c'était au
tournoi de saint sinatti écoles wilander
l'avait déjà emporté
bilan d'air dans le lobe lycée est
toujours extrêmement redoutable pour ses
adversaires
dans la deuxième demi finale alors que
qui est en train de se dérouler et bien
mcenroe est opposé à jarryd et là c'est
la première fois cette année que les
deux joueurs se rend compte
nous les reverrons certainement dans un
mois et demi à göteborg pour la finale
de la coupe davis entre la suède
mats wilander en tête et les états unis
me lambert va remporter donc ce match
6-7 6-3 6-3 et vilander et donc qualifié
pour la finale c'est lui le tenant du
titre de ce tournoi
deux copains
sur un dernier retour dans le filet de
14 victoires de wieland
dernière dépêche c'est confirmé le
niçois jean charles orso troisième ligne
centre blessé aujourd'hui en championnat
de france ce contre nîmes ne pourra
jouer le match contre la roumanie samedi
prochain diffusé en direct d'ailleurs
sur antenne 2 ce match aura lieu à
bucarest orso souffre en effet d'une
fracture d'un poignet on souhaite que le
sourire de christine ockrent que nous
retrouvons maintenant la douce 6 un peu
ses douleurs l'espère en tout cas une
information importante avec les
résultats du car c'est qui s'est couru
tout à l'heure à auteuil
à l'arrivée vous allez le voir l'as les
voix si elle arrivait donc l'as le 4 et
le 8 de bien maigres au rapport 4 155
francs pour 5 francs placés dans l'ordre
et dans un ordre différent 91 francs et
maintenant laurent boussier va nous
parler du temps de demain qui va être
plus frais oui demain c'est novembre qui
commence mais attention havrais mois de
novembre avec des nuages de la pluie et
des températures frisquettes regardons
la photo satellite
la dépression qui vient se coller contre
les côtes du portugal dirige vers notre
pays
une perturbation qui demain va recouvrir
presque toutes les régions de la france
la carte pour demain et donc une fois de
plus recouverte de nuages mais avant de
nous occuper du temps regardons les
températures minimales les gelées seront
présentes dans la nuit surtout le
nord-est du pays
sur l'alsace la lorraine la
franche-comté et l'est champagne-ardenne
-1 à -2 degrés c'est normal en cette
saison le temps maintenant et bien il
sera ensoleillé sur ce que ces mêmes
régions du nord-est et pluvieux nuageux
avec quand même quelques éclaircies sur
une grande partie du pays
attention quelques orages sont en sont à
craindre pardon sur les cévennes
les pressions sont en baisse les
températures sont en très légère hausse
de 10 à 16 degrés sur la moitié nord et
de 12 11 pardon à 20° encore sur la
moitié sud
on retrouve notre agenda comme tous les
soirs demain c'est le lundi 5 novembre
le soleil se lève à 7h43 se couche à
17h24 c'est la sainte sylvie et puis
comme le week end de toussaint ne se
termine vraiment que demain quelques
conseils de bison futé des derniers
retours qui occasionneront encore
malheureusement des ralentissements en
province
au cours de l'après midi en ile de
france c'est là où la situation risque
d'être la plus ennuyeuse sur les
autoroutes du sud et de l'ouest qui
connaîtront des bouchons il faut donc
essayer de partir soit tôt le matin soit
tard le soir après le journal d'antenne
2 à 23h15 ce soir c'est hervé claude qui
vous présentera notre dernière édition
demain 12h40 cinquantaine de midi 18h30
c'est la vie et j'aurai le plaisir de
vous retrouver demain amateurs très
bonne soirée